تيك توك يدخل في كل تفاصيل الحياه هذه
المقوله اصبحت حقيقه لا مفر منها حتى انه
اصبح يتفوق في عالم الادب والقراءه ايضا
اسهام تيك توك الادبي اظهرته احصائيات
رصدت رصدت في معرض كتاب باريس الذي نظم
قبل نحو شهر من الان منظموا المعرض اكدوا
ان اكثر من 50 الف من الشباب زاروا
ارويقته في اقبال منقطع النظير مرجعين ذلك
الى القوه الدعائيه لتسويق تيك توك
كذلك حسدت روايه اغنيه تخيل للمؤثره
الشباب مادلين ميلر اكثر من 20 مليون
مشاهده وذابت مبيعاتها الى تسعه اضعاف في
الولايات المتحده وسته اضعاف في فرنسا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
دراسات عده تظهر مجموعه من الفوائد
النفسيه والصحيه لقراءه الكتب ومنها بحسب
مقاله نشرت في موقع
ايضا القراءه يمكن ان تزيد من القدره على
التعاطف لدى الشباب رؤيه العالم بالتاكيد
من خلال الشخصيه يمكن الارتباط بها عبر
روايه ما او تخيل شخصيه ما
قراته او بحثت عنها بالفعل كذلك فان
القراءه يمكن ان تساعد الشباب على التقليل
من التوتر بشكل فعال ويصفها بعض اطباء
النفس كعلاج للاكتئاب يعرف باسم العلاج
بالقراءه ويقول خبراء ان لها قوه فعاله
تعادل ممارسه اليوغا القراءه ايضا علامه
قويه من علامات تنميه الفضول المفيد لدى
صغار السن فهي تنمي تعطش المعرفه والفهم
لديهم وتساهم في تحسين جوده العقول ورقيه
ورقي العقول ايضا وقدره هذه العقول على
تحكيم الامور
[موسيقى]
هنا تنضم الينا في الاستوديو الكاتبه
والاعلاميه الدكتوره بروين حبيب صباح
الخير صباح الفل صباح السعاده
استجاب المجتمع لنداء اطلق من بدايه
السوشيال ميديا او المواقع لا تجعله من
الحمقى مشاهير واتجه الى الثقافه نعم لا
تجعله من
الحمقى البلهاء طبعا ايقونات ورموز هذه
طبعا اطلقها امبرتو ايكو هذه المقوله عن
تاثير السوشيال ميديا على الناس وخصوصا
انه صاروا في حاله له وتكاسل وصعود يعني
تافهين للاسف واصبحوا يسودون العالم
ويقودون العالم للاسف لكن الان اعتقد
السوشيال ميديا خرجت من هذه
الدائره السلبيه لنقل خصوصا في الغرب حيث
اطلقت فرنسا
يعني حمله حمله عن ان التيك توك تحديدا
نافذه على العالم وهناك مبيعات فعلا في
الغرب
صعود مثلا الجاردين البريطانيه يعني تكتب
يوميا عن هذا الشيء خصوصا ان في روائيين
يعني تاثروا في المبيعات يعني مثلا في
روائيه كانت مطلعه روايه في 2014
وخمدت هذه الروايه مبيعاتها لكن صار في
تفعيل بسبب قارئه قرات وفعلت
وتاثرت بالضبط عبر التيك توك فصعدت ايضا
المبيعات فهناك في تاثير هذا في الخارج
هذا بعلمنا بالعالم العربي هل رواد مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي جاهزون انهم يتركوا له
على الاقل او انه يعني يوجهوا طاقاتهم
واهتماماتهم
بالسوشيال ميديا ولكن لشيء اكثر عمق واكثر
قيمه مثل القراءه او الشعر او غيره
بالنسبه للعمق هذه نقطه جدا جوهريه
اعتقد احنا ما زلنا ندور في نفس الفلك
التاثيرات السلبيه لهذه الاشياء
التيك توك هذه المنصات لم تستخدم ولم توظف
التوظيف الذكي
لتفعيل يعني مفهوم القراءه المشكله
المشكله التطبيقات او مشكل
الذين يروجون للكتب ما نوعيه الكتب ماذا
يقراون هل هي الكتب الكتب اللايت كتب
التنميه البشريه هذه
اليوم يعني الشباب احتفي معارض الكتاب
الروايات التي بدات تنتشر هي ما ينظر
اليها النخبه انها كلام مقاهي او صفحتي
مجرد صفحتي هل المشكله في مواقع التواصل
ولا مشكله المؤلف مؤلف الروايه او الكتاب
اللي مو قادر يوصل الى
انتقاء
يعني الانتقاء صاير باتجاه ترويج الكتب
التنميه البشريه
المسليه كتب الترفيه مش الكتب الجاده
الكتب المتطابقه
هنا في هنا هنا الكتب هنا انت تصنع فارق
تصنع ذائقه تصنع مزاج تصنع قارئ نوعي ايضا
يعني هي اليوم مثلا كتب مثل نظريه الفستق
او نظريه مثلا فن اللامبالاه او الرقص مع
الحياه هذه كتب يعني لا ليست عميقه تكلمت
يمكن
ادبيه كمان لحتى يعني تفيد او تغني وتثري
اللغه الافكار لهذا الشخص ولكن يعني انا
باعتقادي تشجيع على القراءه حتى لو قراءه
هذه الكتب بدايه اللي ليس فقط لديها
الكثير من العمق شيء افضل من لا شيء افضل
من عدم القراءه افضل من لا شيء وهذا اللي
صار بالضبط في الغرب في فرنسا تحديدا يعني
اوبستان صاحب اشهر برنامج ثقافي فرنسا عند
برنامج المكتبه الكبيره كانوا يعني قبل
ذلك كانوا يمنعون ظلما لبعض الكتب الخفيفه
مثل كتب المانجا هل سمعتم عن كتب المانجا
الكتب المصوره اليابانيه هذه الكتب كانت
ممنوعه مثل كتب الرومانسيه القاتمه مثل
كتب خيال التاريخي مثلا هذه الكتب فتحت مع
التيك توك يعني فكوا القيود عن هذه لان
اكتشفوا ان هذه الكتب هي الاكثر مبيعا
تمثل نصف المبيعات الفرنسيه في المعارض
فلذلك من الظلم ان احنا ايضا ننظر لها
بانها دون علاقه لكن في نفس الوقت نحن
نريد ان نوجه يعني القراء والضائقه باتجاه
الكتب القيمه الكتب اللي فيها رساله فيها
عمق فيها ما راح اقول للرساله مفهوم
الرساله لكن فيها فكر فكر لان
نحن نحتاج الى الفكر اليوم الحقيقه يعني
للاسف انتهى وقتنا والحديث معك لا يمل
فبشكرك جزيل الشكر الكاتبه والاعلاميه
دكتوره برمين شكرا لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات